european union ministers have reached
agreement on new rules governing the way
information about agricultural products
is promoted on europe's internal market
as well as to the outside world
the rules would better inform consumers
and stakeholders
about the quality of food produced in
europe to help boost competitiveness and
find new markets
we now have a mandate to negotiate
with the european parliament i dare
to say that this file is a close to
conclusion
and we hope soon to be able to adopt
a proposal at first reading before
the end of the term of office of the
current parliament
the ministers also heard a report from
the european commission on the
possibility of broadening rules
on mandatory origin labeling for meat
views differ among the member states on
the issue many favor mandatory labeling
for meat used as an ingredient
with some wanting the specific country
of origin marked
others prefer labeling to be done on a
voluntary basis
the report weighs the need for consumer
information against the costs
and feasibility of introducing such a
system
the commission also presented a proposal
for new rules on organic production and
farming
and the labeling of organic products the
aims to simplify legislation and cut red
tape
as well as tighten controls on the
industry
fisheries ministers meanwhile discussed
a new five-year arrangement for managing
stocks of mackerel
in the north east atlantic the coastal
state's mackerel arrangement involves
the eu
norway and the faroe islands and allows
joint management of the stock so that
fishing remains sustainable
the ministers expressed regret that
iceland was not taking part